foreign
I do want to start in a slightly unusual
place with a look at what we're doing
when we ask these questions about the
boundaries of moral consideration
philosophers often make a pretty sharp
distinction between normative ethics
where we ask what we should do and meta
ethics where we ask what are we up to
when we spend time working out what we
should do now philosophers talking about
these particular matters around I've
noticed around animal ethics they quite
often dive into the normative side
and treat the meta-ethical questions as
totally separate but also approach the
normative side in a way that includes
what I see as an implicit commitment to
a particular view on the meta-ethical
side and one that I think has problems
and problems that those those very
philosophers would probably recognize if
they were thinking purely about that
side of it
trying to move very fast into some basic
issues here what I have in mind here is
largely the question when we're working
through a moral problem of this kind are
we uncovering hidden ethical facts
discovering how things are in this very
unusual area or are we essentially
making creating choosing in a way not
based on Discovery our values of the
kind relevant in this setting created or
discovered now that's not a simple
divide a person might say values are
created or constructed
but there's only one way to do it that's
coherent that's a kind of neo-kantian
approach to these questions or a person
might say
um we're choosing
but we're choosing to follow particular
discoveries that were made here so a
particular blend of the two
now often there seems to be something to
be said on both on both sides we create
value systems in order to live together
as a kind of conceptual and social
technology but they feel once at least
they're mature not at all arbitrary it
feels like you can get things wrong here
and it's hard to make good sense of what
it is to get things right or wrong here
philosophy has a standard menu of
options for how our language in this
area might be working sort of moral
philosophy textbook options such as the
idea that moral claims might be seen as
attempted descriptions they might be
seen as expressions of emotion or
sentiment they might be seen as commands
I think all those standard options are
not very good roughly in the direction
of being too simple
we need a kind of mixed view but what
kind of mixed view well I'll quickly
sketch what I think of as a sensible
mixed view through a kind of historical
or etiological approach looking at how
we got where we are and this will be of
course the quickest of sketches
I start from the idea that valuation
itself is inescapable putting options in
order choosing between them working out
what to do and at a large scale working
out how to live
the moral or the ethical side of life is
part of this practice of evaluation a
part that relates especially but not
only to social life to cooperation group
cohesion
um patterns of behavior of that kind now
it's not only that I think Jonathan
height has quite successfully shown that
much but it is a central part
eventually in human history with the
development of more elaborate social
life and language Norms that began
implicit are made explicit Norms are
made explicit as rules and they thereby
come into contact with reasoning and
reflection they become part of
intellectual life with consistency as a
constraint the following I think is
especially important the role of parity
claims in the justification of moral
positions
um the kind of reasoning you see when
someone says well if you say that about
X then you also have to say the same
kind of thing about y because X and Y
are similar in so many respects
the things I'm calling explicit
principles here uh or that project
probably often began in a theological
setting but theological but theology can
eventually take a back seat and once
humans can reason reason tends to get
directed on everything
the place we get to at the end of this
historical process is something like
this I see our project here still as
fundamentally a constructive creative
one working out how to live working out
how we want to live what we will value I
think that in the area of morality free
construction is more basic than
Discovery I don't think the universe as
a whole or at large gives us much
guidance here
but on the other side we are committed
to reasonableness to the social function
of moral thinking to respecting parity
arguments you know this is comparable to
that so they should be treated similarly
and to making choices that are
defensible
a moment ago I expressed the kind of
General frustration and dissatisfaction
with the standard views of moral
language that you'll find in moral
philosophy summaries as descriptions as
commands as expressions of sentiments I
can now add that I think moral language
of the thought that we all live within
is almost designed to defy the standard
options that you'll have in these
initial philosophical treatments it's
almost designed socially designed to
defy them for reasons that make sense
because that language is a tool for and
results from the bringing of the
prescriptive building side of human
thought into the realm of explicit
formulation defense and reasonableness
uh Simon Blackburn uh the view I'm
sketching here owes a lot to Blackburn
uh especially his book ruling passions
the difference between Blackburn's
orientation my orientation is partly
that I see Simon I can say this because
he's not here and he's got no way to
defend himself I see himself as having
just too much affection for David Hume
at the end of the day Hume kind of rules
Simon uh Simon is the slave of the Hume
and I'm less of a human than that for
those of you who sort of are familiar
with the names there's more hair than
Hume in in my picture of things
okay with all that on the table as a
kind of Overture
um here is our problem again
re-expressed
as part of our continually evolving
relationships with animals domestic
animals wild animals ecosystems also
plants microorganisms
how might we reasonably establish or
re-establish boundaries relating to
whose well-being is given some weight
some consideration in our decisions and
what kind of well-being matters and what
kind of weight might it have so that's
that's a reformulation of the project
and I'm going to start with a look at
sentience this is the least
controversial feature with respect to
moral consideration uh sentience in the
sense of subjective experience but
particularly of a kind that involves
Pleasure and Pain effective or
evaluative experience and many moral
views converge to some extent on the
importance of this
recently a shift has come about through
broadly empirical considerations rather
than philosophical ones basically it
looks like there's a lot more sentience
around than had been supposed in the
animal kingdom now Crustaceans
encephalopods are the clear cases where
previous views had sort of tacitly
assumed none but the evidence is now
quite good I have in mind especially
um
in these two papers really are exemplars
for me on the octopus side when I wrote
other Minds a book about octopuses I
said a little bit about octopus pain but
in a pretty cautious way since then this
paper by Robert crook I think has added
a great deal to the case that octopuses
can in some circumstances feel pain
on the crustacean side I think Robert
Elwood's work is really exemplary here
um and in both cases there's a kind of
sophistication and integration in the
handling of aversive events by the
animals that strongly suggest the
presence of something like pain to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV